eventually jake kumaro may be in that
category as well he has
received some high praise from aaron
rodgers who is just looking for some
receivers he can trust and
rogers has raved about kumaro's ability
to do everything that he expects of him
and and this is a delicate balance you
have to be able to be in the right place
at the right time you have to win that
trust you have to show that you can make
the catch when the ball comes your way
and rogers just went on and on about
what he does he says it's innate that uh
that that that's what separates him from
a guy you might not trust as much
because you know that he's going to do
it right he's always going to be in the
right spot he knows what he's doing all
the time and what the other guys are
doing and when he gets a chance to make
plays he makes plays and he does it in a
super classy understated way now i don't
know why that matters but apparently
it's a factor for aaron rodgers and
ultimately the quarterback decides who
he's going to throw to chris let me put
this to you yeah was there ever a guy on
the field that you either felt like i
want to throw it to him because i like
how he plays regardless of whether he's
open or a guy that would be open but you
just didn't like that you shied away
from throwing the ball too well
definitely i mean you know to go on the
positive one first right like i'll go
with a guy like ike hilliard ikiliard
was like our slot receiver with the
tampa bay buccaneers he gave me a warm
and cozy feeling one because i knew he
was smart he was gonna read the defense
the right way and if the play broke down
i knew he could try to make the proper
adjustment and like give me a uh you
know get out of jail for free pass where
he'd find the right hole in the zone to
settle down and i just trusted that he
would see things the same way i would
and for that yes he was always one of my
go-to guys because i felt that trust
within him and i think that's what
rogers is trying to say you know so many
of these routes especially by slot
receivers and things in the nfl it is
read the coverage read the defense on
the go rogers thinks he's breaking out
oh gosh he broke in now it's an
interception pick six and you know we're
losing a game and those few plays can
change a season around in a hurry as we
all know so you got to have that guy
within your offense and i would think
with randall cobb not being there right
now i mean we know they're going to use
devonte adams in the slot a little bit
but they probably need to find that
other guy that can work the middle of
the field and i think that's where
kumaro seems to be in the conversation
to be that guy that runs the option rats
the jerk rats where your read coverage
is on the go and rogers doesn't have to
you know double clutch it or double pump
it to go oh i hope he does the right
thing and then you know it you know
becomes a a downward trend of bad throw
misconnection interception whatever it
may be
so who's the guy that you i was just
telling you
come on come on well no but there were
certain guys where
they were extremely athletic and maybe
more talented than a guy like let's say
with like ike hilliard okay but when
they were certain routes i'd go oh man i
mean this guy's awesome but there were
certain routes where i'd go oh i don't
know i just don't trust him to read the
coverage here i'm gonna play the other
side here yeah he's awesome if he's on
the outside and he's going to run a go
route or a comeback or a slant i trust
him there but there was yeah some
talented receivers i played with where i
went oh they went in the slot and now
they're going to run the i kill your
play from the slot i don't know about
this unless it's like just this absolute
clean you know
elementary look to where i go okay he
won't screw that up yeah you'd be scared
to do it but no i'm not gonna give any
names and getting all my ex-teammates
mad at me and beat me up or anything
like that
was there ever a guy that you resisted
throwing the ball to because he kept
complaining that he was open and you
weren't throwing in the ball no no i
can't say that i did i mean that's
almost every receiver ever in the
history of football i mean it's unreal
whether i was in college the nfl
receivers coming over telling you
they're open mike telling you they're
open then you get a picture right and
you sit down to your coach and you know
you got your quarterback coach next year
who's heard the receiver tell you he's
opening right and you're looking at it
and you're going wait isn't that the
play that you know johnny just said he
was open on and the coach looks at the
picture and you look at the picture and
he goes yeah don't listen to him he
doesn't know what he's talking about and
you know there's four guys around him
there's a i can't tell you how many
instances that happens receivers and
what they think is open is not always
open to a quarterback or realistically
open in general
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports